the storage
of the fear memory and that is not just
a retrieval issue okay so
from the animal side then it's it's more
geared toward the storage aspect yeah
very
purely based on human uh research i read
it
is actually yeah impossible to uh this
entangled the two uh conceptual
frameworks yeah right
yes there are limitations unfortunately
and um going back to the
imagery rescripting uh phenomenon that
you had
you i think you delve deep into it into
a recent 2019 paper
where you discuss you know the role of
imagery scripting in emotional memory
now maybe if we can just briefly talk
about this a little more
just to see whether you know we could
utilize imagery scripting in conjunction
with with let's say
propranolol uh to extend the impact of
modifying fear
in various settings for example online
therapies like is that a
possibility do you think i mean we i
know we briefly talked about how
the fear has we have to be in a
controlled environment where
this has to be properly conducted but
with the introduction of imagery
rescripting
do you think we can do anything in that
regard or
or no we still have certain hard
limitations
um yeah
i think that for instance in for if when
we
um use the uh procedure in
specific fears and phobias but we
actually ask the
participant to approach
for instance the spider or the dog and
and then i mean
usually they would sort of uh run away
because they think if i approach it then
something
very bad happens and then they
experience that that doesn't
happen so this is sort of new something
new it's a new experience and that's
the idea is that this is necessary to
open up
the memory trace uh
and for trauma memory it could be that
especially
sometimes you see traumatized people and
they
went over and over the trauma memory in
the trauma story
and then it's really hard just by going
back
to to open up the memory trace and do
and then when we do a little bit of
rescripting that could help
to destabilize uh the memory
right so so so in a sense it is possible
then to do something in conjunction
with because i know in that study you
did not introduce beta blockers right it
was
purely yeah well or so then so we
we did it we over i did this already so
a couple of times then it's only one
session but i also supervised several
uh um so a recent uh
huge trial and also in the in the past
trial
uh where we only did imagery scripting
but then it's more like a traditional
cognitive behavior treatment then you do
sort of weekly sessions many sessions in
a row
right right